Try by day Joe Rogan
podcast by night all day.
It was a,
that was a nutty scene,
man.
Being there and the Wayans felt surreal.
It felt really nice.
Friendly.
It's,
it happened.
Yeah.
It was like,
it was crazy.
Like the weight of the
event was thick in the air.
It had this feel to it that
was very different than any
other show we'd ever put
together.
I wish I was there that,
that's the one show.
I wish I was that because
it was so special.
It's going to be tough to beat that,
but it'll never be you.
I mean,
you'll have big giant events for sure,
but it'll never be like that because
that was the last block of corruption.
Correct.
I was standing in front of the UFC,
getting into New York.
I got a little worried when I saw,
uh,
where was,
I think I was in Atlanta doing live show.
I saw on the,
on the Twitter,
like the crazy press conference
with Connor doing that stuff.
I'm like,
no,
I'm not.
And it was kind of weird.
I was like,
well,
it seems a little gimmicky,
blah,
blah.
And then the way he looked a little
more serious and then the night of the
fight,
I was like,
I mean,
you couldn't have written a better show.
the,
the fights that night,
the way everything happened,
it was amazing.
Man by amazing bar,
the best UFC I've ever seen.
It was by far the,
the main event was almost,
it was almost bizarre.
It's almost bizarre how good Connors,
almost bizarre the way he
picked apart Eddie Alvarez.
Almost bizarre.
Like magical.
That's almost the word I wanna use.
Correct.
Like he touches motherfuckers.
Would that left hand?
Have you ever seen any average?
Just like they didn't even look
like they were in the same planet.
Like one guy,
like look like he was from Mars.
The other guy look like he's just a
normal dude trying to figure it out.
Well,
it looked like Eddie,
the moment he got hit with like,
what the fuck you could see on his face.
He was like,
holy,
but Jesus,
what am I doing here?
And then he goes,
well,
all right,
he does.
He's not very good at wrestling.
We try this wrestling cutters
like that was your shot,
I'll bro,
you're in for a long night.
I think that he realized like,
Holy Fuck boys already touched up a
little bit when he finally went in for the
shot,
you know?
And I just think I'm Connor new.
Then also that he had
them and how calm was he?
Ridiculous.
Just calm upright and just waiting.
And then the accuracy of that
Combo that finally finished Eddie.
That's what I think makes Connor
show specials is accuracy.
When he throws punches,
Eddie's moving as he's
laying in this stuff.
I've never seen anything like,
like you said,
it was straight up magical.
I'm like,
all right,
well we've never seen a guy like this.
We just have it.
I don't know if we ever,
well either.
It was really interesting too when I
was interviewing him and he's like,
you've gotta have some attributes.
If you want to beat me,
you gotta be tall.
You've got to be big.
It can me.
These guys my size,
what he's doing though,
it,
it's so,
he's a once in a lifetime guy
because he sent in the ceiling.
Like there's no,
there's no boundaries for him.
Like he's just like,
I'll fight Nate at 70 I'll be 45 sure
on merch Aldo in 13 seconds and they'll
come to 55 like we've never seen this
kind of creativity and we've often never
seen the UFC allow
someone to do this either.
Yeah.
Well he's just such a unique personality.
It's undeniable,
but also his style in a lot of ways.
He kind of does a lot of
lightweight Wonderboy does,
but with less kicks,
like he throws kicks to the body,
I'll throw it some front kicks.
I mean,
you know,
like maybe 70% has many kicks.
Wonderboy is a little more kick heavy,
but it's that sideway style and he's,
but he,
he,
I think he does it better.
Like there's maybe something about the
focus of the shots that he's landing,
the precision of them,
cause Wonderboy very rarely like touches
somebody up like that with a punch.
He just doesn't have that kind of power.
Yeah,
you're right.
I think Wonderboy is better at surprising
guys with his kicks in his ankles,
but commerce set it up and he's landing
combos that are all so precise in this
power,
like he's touching dudes and you can
see it on their face touched Eddie and
Eddie's like,
what duff?
Well,
not only that,
and he's like,
he's hitting him in a surprise
way is not telegraphing it at all.
Like his ability to like go from bouncing
around to launching that shot is so
quick.
It's so,
it's so precise and it's so focused
and there's no fat in his movements.
It's just yet,
and they said there's gonna be a
big announcement afterwards enough,
these girls pregnant,
which I mean it's a personal
big announcement for him,
but I think he's,
he said he's going to take time off
and he wants a piece of the pie.
He wants a piece of WME and what,
you know what they're doing now,
which,
which is hilarious.
Right.
I love it.
Me Too.
And he's the first fighter
ever that can talk like this.
How old is he was kind of 26 maybe 27 26
gotta think 28 I think
he's a smart guy too.
I don't,
I mean I would hope at least I don't
see him fight and deep into his thirties
no,
especially the way he
talked because he goes,
now that I have a kid,
I know what I bring to the table.
I won't be set financially
for the rest of my life.
You guys want me to fight again?
You know I'm leaving.
You need to be set for
the rest of my life.
I want to,
I want to part of this pie and he's,
he's his next fight and it's going
to be such a fight is with WME.
It's not with anyone out there.
If you think he's fighting
for and it could be next.
You're batshit crazy.
That's not happening for a very long time.
Maybe.
Maybe they work it out.
I don't think so.
I think the next slide,
again,
I don't know.
This is just me going off
whatever the hell I think Joe,
but I think his next fight would be Nate
for the belt at 55 because if you think
if you like,
it could be even Tony,
they're both deserving and we're MMA.
Pierce were balls deep in MMA.
We love it and one of
those guys deserves it.
As far as numbers and
and in a big paper view,
it would have to be native to really
think they would do Nate again,
100% wow.
I don't think Nader economy will
fight unless it's an if it's,
that's the,
if that has to be the matchup,
I think Connor will fight someone else.
I think Connor might
even fight Woodley you.
I think you'd see a fight with Woodley
before you see could be by Ferguson I
think could be in first and will
fight each other before anything else.
Do you know how fucking crazy it would
be if he decided to go up and fight
Woodley?
It's so nice.
Obviously Willie has get
through Wonderboy again,
but it doesn't,
it has to.
You think so?
Well we'll,
Dana said that's an immediate rematch.
A lot of shit.
He says God is fighting for the title.
It's good point.
It was like,
Nah,
we sure you're fighting for a title.
Nah.
Yeah,
he does that all the time.
I don't think that means anything.
Thanks.
Good point.
I'm just going based
off what your boys said.
He was like,
that's the next rematch,
but put it on me
more your friend than mine.
Your you've worked on forever.
Yeah.
I liked it and I just think you
know you have a closer relationship,
so let's say you're a boy,
but he does say things and pulls back.
Yeah.
If if Woodley and that's there.
This other thing you got
to worry about though,
not,
you don't have to worry about
something to think about.
How much power or are they going to give
Connor 45 55 70 just wraps up all the
dude.
Do you know how crazy that
would be if he did it though?
I say let them do it.
Let them try it.
UFC,
he's going,
we can't,
he's going to take this pitch Woodley.
We'll say,
let him try.
Fuck yeah.
Woodlea say,
let him try whether we'd love that dude.
How crazy.
That mass square garden and after the
fight the lights on the state in which
they've never done before in the arena.
We're Irish colors.
It was pretty intense.
Do you,
and Brian and I were arguing this,
do you think Conor McGregor is more
well known than Floyd Mayweather?
Currently?
Yes.
Because boxing's a bigger sport.
Yeah.
Cause you look at,
did you look at Floyd
Manny like the paper,
your numbers destroys anything
cottage or been close to.
That's true.
Maybe not.
Maybe.
No.
I was arguing Connor is bigger.
He loves social media,
stuff like that.
But Floyd has more
followers and on Instagram,
Twitter.
But you can't judge it off that.
Here's the thing,
the amount of excitement that Floyd
generates does not even fucking compare to
the amount of excitement
that Connor generates.
It doesn't mean he's more popular.
Understand,
but it does kind of,
because the intensity of the popularity,
the love people might know
who Floyd Mayweather is,
but when it comes to how many
people love Floyd Mayweather,
it's not even close.
He might be like some ridiculous 10 to
one or 20 to one because when Connor gets
out there,
they go fucking crazy.
Crazy.
How many people were there
to see Floyd Mayweather lose?
How many people were bored after Floyd
Mayweather fights like Floyd Mayweather
fights so skillfully and surgically that
and doesn't take any chances for hardly
ever gets hit.
It's not Connor Merck's motherfuckers.
He wins the world title and the fastest
ever title winning knockout ever.
What did you do after that?
He comes back and makes
Eddie Alvarez look.
Eddie Alvarez world champion,
the guy was,
he's defending hall of Fame Hall of Famer
and Connor makes him look like he has
no business in there with them.
No business has zero success at all
except for a couple of body shots.
This is why I think Connor's bigger
and more trend descent because you just
bailed on that word.
I did.
Sorry.
Marin's send a transcendent
p because I just bailed.
Right?
Just fucking out like that.
Sometimes I'll just like,
yeah,
I was like,
I think I'm using it wrong.
[inaudible]
out and operation.
He Jacks.
Um,
but how many successful black
athletes do we know of Joe Galen?
How many white Irish
superstars do we know?
One?
Yeah.
One one weekend was a big star before
he came to the United States and he came
to the United States and
eventually lost his belt.
But Barry Mcwiggin at one
point in time was a huge star,
but nowhere near [inaudible]
the connoisseur worldwide in,
in this,
it goes for all athletes.
Connors,
the green elephant in the room,
everyone else we've seen before,
every once we know what
they can kind of do.
Connors,
this green elephant amongst all these
gray elephants and there's nothing like
him.
Totally different.
Totally different animal.
It's crazy.
He's elephant with two fucking trunks.
Got It.
15 decks,
15 days to China,
gold with a Leprechaun outfit,
our act.
And now he has a little son on the way
and they gave him a fucking Rolls Royce
with his face on it.
How crazy is that?
What's interesting is how
well he manages it all.
It's really interesting.
You know,
like the,
the pressure in particular,
he doesn't seem to have
a problem with it at all.
It's weird.
That's what makes him so special because
that magnitude and the pressure and he
has to deliver and he has to do
those antics and then back it up,
but he keeps pulling it off like
you at the press comes like,
all right,
this is stupid man.
This is getting old to me.
But then we pull it off.
I'm like,
that was brilliant and you know,
I mean the guy steps in,
he loses to ds,
right?
Takes the Diaz fight on short notice.
By the way,
after a staph infection,
here's something that a lot
of people don't even know.
He had a pretty significant staph
infection was on antibiotics until like I
think two weeks before the fight.
If you don't think that
drains your gas tank,
you never had a staph infection and
he never had to take antibiotics.
Antibiotics are brutal on your,
on your respiratory system.
They're brutal on your whole body.
It's just your body.
When your body is made up of all this
shit that you don't consider it to be you,
but it is you.
The stomach flora is a real part of you.
You know,
your body is essentially like an ecosystem
and when you have a staph infection,
staph infections are dangerous.
It's fuck.
And people die from them then.
So they hit you with some
heavy duty antibiotics.
I've had staff twice and it's not fun.
And the first time I had it
and I took the medication,
I couldn't believe how I felt so weird.
I felt light headed.
I felt weak.
I was like,
Whoa,
I can drained.
Right.
You have no energy.
Super strong stuff too.
And I was like,
wow,
imagine this guy fighting
two weeks after that saying,
because there's no way you Pete correctly.
No.
So it comes from that.
And then he fights Nate again,
you know,
few months later in a fucking crazy
five round war and beats him by the
narrowest of margins.
Right.
Don't you agree?
Yeah.
Those are the very,
very close fight were some
people thought that Nate one,
I mean,
I thought there the decision was correct,
but I was like,
wow,
that's close fight.
So takes that fucking crazy chance.
Comes back at fights.
That guy.
He kind of weighed one 69 that's
what he weighed when he weighed in.
That's what he weighed during the fight,
and they want him to fight at 55 he goes,
no,
no.
I can beat him at 70 let me do 70 Nate
wade probably around one 90 something.
Yeah,
I mean did I mean,
everybody says that Nate is 155 pounder.
He is 100% but he's a way bigger man.
They been then congress,
he just is,
you know,
so it's like,
who's going to weigh more
when they actually get in
there and Nate's gonna weigh
more.
So he does that and then goes
from there and just see starches.
Eddie Alvarez like a world beater
and just so relaxed and loosened.
They're so amazing.
Fucking Madonna was at the show.
Madonna was Madonna.
Madonna was at the fights.
How crazy is that?
Madonna's instagramming Mama.
We made it Mama.
We made this red penny night.
It's red panty night and Madonna,
Europe thinks she's single with a focus.
My second belt,
I envisioned this where the focus me,
belt nuts,
man.
Yeah.
He's fucking actor,
man.
He's such a character.
And you know,
I thought he was gonna
make a big announcement.
I thought it's announcement
was he's going to retire,
but his nephew was like a life
I'm going to continue doing.
So you guys need to,
I need a share of the company.
Yeah.
That's probably what the announcement
was going to be all along.
You know that he wants a piece of the Pie.
I mean he's got an argument that he
probably should get a percentage of the
promotion because the,
what they're selling is Conor McGregor
or selling the UFC plus Conor McGregor.
The question is how much of that card,
what would it be?
What would the paper,
we don't know what the numbers are.
So let's pretend the number is 2 million,
which would be like the
greatest card of all time.
Right?
It probably wouldn't hit that.
I don't know.
I bet it's in one seven.
Let's just say 2 million.
Cause it's easy to correct.
So,
so let's say that,
what percentage bought
it because it Connor,
it might be a million.
1 million plus for sure
might be 1 million,
1 million plus for sure.
1 million people might have bought the
paper view specifically because of one
human being.
That is not outrageous to say [inaudible]
but this is the other thing in
Connor's favorite name,
another star who can do that.